I've got a story for you today about
totally scum riddled swamp filling by
the Trump administration remember drain
the swamp the reality is that Donald
Trump has filled the swamp in a way that
we've not seen a recent president do
this story is flat-out sick
you'll probably be aware of the fact
that Puerto Rico is completely hurricane
ravaged we've talked about it before and
Trump was barely paying attention to
what happened in Puerto Rico as a result
of the hurricanes until it became this
major media scandal all of a sudden we
have Trump in the middle of it we've got
a humanitarian crisis in Puerto Rico
Trump shows up there he's shooting paper
towel rolls like they're basketballs to
people they're tons of people without
water tons of people without power in
fact most people in Puerto Rico still
without power and we've now learned that
a contract has been awarded to help get
the power back on in Puerto Rico great
news right 300 million dollar contract
who got the contract white fish energy
all right
who cares white fish energy what's the
big deal white fish energy is a tiny
company that had two full-time employees
on the day that Hurricane Maria hit
Puerto Rico why would this random tiny
company from Montana get this 300
million dollar contract in Puerto Rico
sort of weird kind of seems like a
project for a bigger player maybe one
with more than two employees will it
just happens total coincidence folks
believe me that the company is located
in the hometown of Donald Trump's
interior secretary Ryan Zinke how are
they even doing the work with just two
employees while they're subcontracting
they are now subcontracting 280 workers
on the puerto rican island former senior
official at energy 2-part at the energy
department was asked about this asked is
it weird or is it normal that a company
that's so small and in montana would get
this [ __ ] is contract and susan tyranny
a former Energy Department official said
this is weird
quote the fact that there are so many
utilities with experience in this and a
huge track record of helping each other
out it is at least odd
why the utility would go to Whitefish
I'm scratching my head wondering how it
all adds up
whitefish energy spokesman Chris chimes
was asked about this and he said to a
local newspaper that whitefish energy is
taking quote personal risks and business
risks and working in perilous physical
and financial conditions well their
subcontractors I guess are taking the
risks right normally when you have such
a natural disaster you use a much bigger
company and I would advise you to follow
the money because other than the
connection to trumps interior secretary
Ryan's inky's hometown there's also a
private equity firm here that is
connected to Trump there's a private
equity firm called HBC investments that
firm is financing whitefish energy the
general partner of HBC investments is
Joe Collin etta he donated 20 grand to
Donald Trump's to the Trump victory pack
he donated the maximum $2,700 to Donald
Trump's primary campaign he donated
$2,700 to Trump's general election
campaign and donated thirty thousand
seven hundred dollars to the Republican
National Committee in 2016 alone it
doesn't stop there Collin Etta's wife
gave over $33,000 to the RNC right after
Donald Trump was elected president of
the United States and whitefish chief
executive officer and e-tec Manske is
friends with Donald Trump's interior
secretary Ryan's Enki but don't worry
this company with two full-time
employees is absolutely the best to get
power back on in Puerto Rico I looked at
their Facebook page and now the Facebook
page for white fish that energy has been
taken over by trolls but before that
they had a hundred five-star reviews
that's pretty interesting they all came
in during the last four days very
obvious public relations strategizing to
try to make this company look good so
what's the bottom line the bottom line
is that this stinks endlessly this is
putting white fish in as a middleman to
suck money out of the deal that's all
that this is white fish is functioning
as a middleman and pulling some portion
of
at 300 million dollars out of this while
its subcontractors on the island doing
the actual work they had two employees -
when Hurricane Maria hit and now they
get handed a 300 million dollar contract
and the company just so happens to be
from the hometown of Donald Trump's own
interior secretary now nothing shady
about that other than the fact that it
is the lowest form of crony capitalist
swamp filling that Trump said he was
going to end he said he would come in
and end this stuff and he's doing it
front and center and it is reprehensible
and he seems to have absolutely no shame
about it whatsoever now I want to speak
directly for a second to our Trump
supporters in the audience and I know
that you're there I get the anti-semitic
emails from you if you believe that this
is no big deal if you think that this is
good email me and explain to me why this
is good and if you make any sense if
you're clear I will read your email on
the show and we'll see if we agree
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the 5 pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS